in the first movie that made me feel
seen
what a great question that's always a
tough one it really was a huge moment
when Rupert Everett was in My Best
Friend's Wedding playing such a pivotal
scene stealing role as a gay character
being played by an openly gay man Cooley
High just great looking brown boys and
girls having a good time and doing the
things that I did it's a toss between
Frankenstein and Pinocchio the
abandonment of a son that had to figure
out the world and ultimately to exist a
little outside quote-unquote the normal
so I identifying very much in the
bedroom really beautifully paced
portrait of grief and guilt The Graduate
feeling out of place trying to trying to
Define yourself that movie just captured
a lot of the insecurities that I was
feeling and it also was just incredibly
cool I was like a science fiction kid I
really related because he was sort of
Outsider and by himself and alone
exploring the universe Dave Bowman from
2001 Space Odyssey I want to say it's
school days it's a film that I was a
costume designer on but I felt seen in
that film Paris Texas I remember being
very hunted or and affected and impacted
by it West Side Story was the first
movie that represented the diversity of
the world that I lived in I saw Death of
a Salesman as a movie and I was floored
I saw it 12 times when I saw the Tuscan
Raiders there was two of them on screen
and that one of them was getting the
other one's attention by tapping on
their shoulder
and as a child when I saw that that
specific moment of communication I felt
a connection to it because of that
gesturing that sign language and it
happened in the first Star Wars It's
called crazy beautiful it was about a
teenage girl and she was really messy
and kind of disastrous and uh I just
really loved it boys in the hood
and then also he got game where there
were two that really had an impact on me
I grew up in the 80s anything with Molly
ringwalds probably Pretty in Pink
I think was probably E.T I think it was
that red hoodie that connection with
that alien and that soundtrack by John
Williams
I don't know why when I grew up I just
realized that I have this feeling of
having a double life the rose with Pat
Midler there's a woman and she was a
young woman and she's up there singing
and bringing so much to that I loved it
it was for sure to do the right thing
those were lives personalities that I
recognized the thing that's great about
movies is it's it's so many different
parts of me get seen right so like the
part of me that needed to obsess about
Ace Ventura is just as important as the
Five Easy Pieces or All That Jazz
Terminator 2. and I think that's why
movies can feel like they're giving you
company I would say that it was The
Wizard of Oz was good old red shoes and
the wonderful Judy Garland clicking
those heels and leaving in magic